Oh, oh, oh, wait!
Camera was already running. Sorry.
Sorry, guys.
Functional programming with bananas
lenses, the barbed wire
I left at home and envelopes
is not something for hipsters.
It is actually a style of functional programming
where we leverage higher-order functions.
And that will be the topic of today's
lecture.
We have seen several higher-order
functions already, but we never actually
named them specifically. A higher-order
function
is a function that takes a function
as an argument
or returns a function as a result.
Let's look at this function twice. Twice
is defined as follows: twice of f and x
calls
f of f of x. If we look at the type
of twice
and again remember the syntax, twice
double colon means twice has type,
then on the right we see that it takes
as the first parameter a function
from a to a and it returns a function
from a to a. And if we look at the
definition again with that type in mind
we see that that type makes sense. Twice
takes a function, that function goes from
a to a
then it takes an argument of type a
that's x and then it returns a value of
type a. How does it do that?
It applies f once
which takes an a and transforms that
into another a
so the argument to the second
application of f will also be of
type a
and you apply f a second time to
return
a value of type a.
So twice is a higher-order function
because it takes a function as its first
argument.
Also notice how the parentheses are
used. The parentheses on the first
argument
are explicit, because it's a function
from a to a and the
brackets for function types associate to
the right. So we have to put
the parentheses there, but we don't have
to put them
on the right hand side. But if we would
put all the parentheses there
the type would look (a -> a) ->
(a -> a). Why are
higher-order functions useful? Well,
there is this
thing that programmers love to do, and
that is not to repeat yourself.
Don't repeat yourself. And with higher
order functions
we allow this thing to be encoded in the
language, because whenever we see
repetition
we abstract that pattern into a
higher-order function
and then we can apply that
with various arguments to specify
what is different between
all the common uses of this
common pattern.
So common programming idioms can be
encoded as functions
within the language itself. And
laziness here plays
an important role, because if you don't
have lazy evaluation
arguments might be evaluated prematurely
and then the effect is not the same as
the
pattern where you instantiate the
arguments
for the parameters. Another
way to look at this is that we can
define
domain-specific languages as a collection
of higher-order functions. In Haskell
people often talk about domain-specific
languages where they mean
API's. Another way to say that
is these are embedded domain-specific
languages.
And then the third
advantage of higher-order functions is
that
these higher-order functions have
algebraic properties
that we can use to reason about
programs. And these
properties
of higher-order functions, these
algebraic properties,
they hold irrespective of
which parameters you pass to them. So
you can
define properties of these programs
in a general way
and then use them all along. And we
will see
several of these examples as we go. Twice
may look a little weird, it's
maybe a little bit
syntactic
but here is another higher-order
function, that we use all the time.
And this is the map function. Map
takes a function and
then takes a list and then applies that
function to
every element of the list. If you look at
the type of map: a arrow b
arrow list of a arrow list of b
you have very little choice than to
apply that function
to every element of the list, because
the type
really strongly suggests that
implementation.
You have a function of type a to b, you
have a
list with values of type a, and what
you require
is a list with values of type b. Well,
what can you do?
You just transform every element in
the input list
using that function to get the
required output list.
That is exactly how map is defined.
Let's look at an application of map.
We map the sectioned plus
function (+1), remember the lecture
we had about sections. So this is a
function that
implicitly defined to be lambda x
x+1
and we map that function over the list
1,3,5,7.
So this function will just add 1 to
every element of the list
and that's what you see there: we get the
result list 2,4,6,8.
We can define the map function using
list comprehensions
very easily. In some sense you can say list
comprehensions
are designed to define
map. Map applies the function f
to every element in the list. There
is the list comprehension.
It is exactly
what I said.
Take every element x out of the list xs
apply f to it and return the list.
That's what map is.
But we can also define map recursively.
And in some sense I prefer myself the
recursive definition.
Why do I prefer the recursive
definition? Well, we will see later
that when we define map recursively
and we define other higher-order functions
recursively
we see a pattern that we can abstract
again. So we can abstract map into a
super higher-order function.
And that will be the fold function. But
for now let's look at the recursive
definition of just map.
Map of the empty list is the empty list.
And map of the list x:xs
what we do is we
first recursively map f over xs
so we map f over the rest of the list
and then we
concatenate f of x to the front.
This is a recursive definition that is
inductive over the structure of the list.
We have
either the empty list or we have the case
where the list
is build using x cons xs.
We recursively map f over the rest of
the list
and then cons f of x on top.
Here is another
higher-order function: filter.
Filter takes
a predicate, a function from a to Bool
then takes a list and returns
another list, a new list
where all the elements, for which that
predicate
does not hold, are removed.
That's why it is called filter. All
these elements are filtered away.
For instance: if we want to filter
all the even numbers from the list
of values from 1 to 10
we get all the even values 2,4,6
8 and 10. Again
filter can be defined in two ways.
First one
is with list comprehensions.
Fairly simple. What we do is we say
take every
element x out of xs and if
p of x is true, then you put x in the
result list
and that's it. So the definition of
filter using list comprehensions
looks very simple, but again I prefer
the recursive definition. And the
recursive definition has a
very very similar structure to the map
function.
It's defined inductively on the structure
of the list.
We have two cases: either we have the
empty list
or we have the list x cons xs.
When we filter all the values for which
this predicate does not hold from the
empty list
the only thing we can do is return the
empty list.
If we filter out all the values
for which p does not hold from the list
x cons xs
there are two cases. First
p of x can be true, so that's this case
and then
this is the second case, when p of x is
false.
If p of x is true, we filter
recursively the rest of the list and
then we
concatenate x on top. And otherwise we
just forget about x
and filter the rest of the list.
Here you see
it is as simple as the
list comprehension definition, but the
important thing
is that this definition here follows
exactly the same structure of map.
And in the context of saying
don't repeat ourselves, we should be able
to abstract
that commonality between filter and map.
They are both recursively defined over
lists. We should be able to factor
that out
into another higher-order function. And
that higher-order
function is foldr. And that will be
the topic
of the next
section. Thank you and see you soon.